what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video we are covering and doing a
breakdown and really the differences
between the comic book version and what
looks like the Marvel Cinematic Universe
TV show version of secret Invasion as
always if you guys dig the content here
make sure you drop a like and make sure
you subscribe but here's the thing the
trailer that we got just shows us that
the secret Invasion event in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is starkly different
from the comic book version and because
there's so many vast differences Easter
eggs seem pretty sparse on our end and
so really we're just gonna kind of do a
comparison and talk about how the
landscape of the MCU could change
drastically as a result of secret
Invasion specifically in relation to how
it sets the stage for the Thunderbolts
and what could potentially be dark rain
in the MCU which would be amazing now
there are some similarities between how
secret Invasion happened in the comics
and how secret invasion is unfolding in
the TV show and in fact Nick Fury is one
of the first things that seemed very
very similar so one of the things that
happens of course in the trailer that we
find out is that Nick Fury is seemingly
picking up on the fact that scrolls are
replacing people that they're replacing
either superheroes or just your average
person or a combination of both and the
result of this is that it requires his
attention like I feel like James Rhodes
is going to turn out to be a scroll I
feel like that's going to be like one of
the big Revelations is that it's not
actually Jim Rhody it's not actually
Roadie at all it's just a scroll
pretending to be him which was one of
the best parts of secret Invasion now in
the comics it happened the exact same
way that there were people who were sort
of figuring things out along the way but
the reality here is that Nick Fury
figured it out before anybody else right
he's the one that realized what was
going on before anybody else did largely
because he's just so damn suspicious but
he immediately went underground and was
super skeptical on who he could trust
for example when he went to go meet with
Spider-Woman Jessica Drew he watched her
for a week before he actually made
contact with her to verify it was
actually her and when I say watch her I
mean watched her almost constantly 24
hours surveillance even in her most
vulnerable moments so it's just one of
those things Nick Fury is kind of creepy
but regardless the similarities seem
very very close to each other right the
Samuel Jackson's Nick Fury in the MCU
seems to be the first one to pick up on
the fact that something's going on here
and they could even bookend if they
wanted to they could literally say okay
in the aftermath of the fall of Shield
or something like that during Captain
America and the Winter Soldier when Nick
Fury initially went underground even
then he was figuring it out like even
then he started to realize something's
going on here with the Scrolls replacing
people something's taking place now of
course the question has to be asked if
the Scrolls were always guys that Allied
themselves with Humanity in the MCU why
would they suddenly turn against the
human race and basically start replacing
us we'll answer that here in a second
because I think I know exactly why it is
that they're doing that now another
possibility here that people are
discussing and I don't really know
exactly how we connect these dots is
that because James Rhodes is being
featured so heavily in secret Invasion
that while I do think it'll be revealed
he is a scroll I think what's also going
to happen is this could potentially
springboard into armor Wars and that's
one of the things to know is that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is taking
stories as we know them from the comics
shifting them around a little bit and
then sending them out to us or they're
shifting them around a lot a bit but the
thing about this is that in the original
armor War story that Tony Stark's
knowledge releases plans for the Iron
Man suits that was basically stolen and
it was just handed out it was given out
to various villains or people who bought
them or whatever but essentially all
these just major players in the villain
landscape suddenly have their own Iron
Man suits based on the technological
plans for the Iron Man suits of Tony
Stark and so it could easily be one of
these things whereby whatever Manner and
whatever means this does springboard
into armor Wars because it basically
leads to the information of how it is
that Tony Stark's Iron Man suits work
which are largely kept under lock and
key are basically handed out now this
could also provide a kind of motivation
for James Rhodes during armor Wars
because if he looks at that information
of Tony Stark's suits basically being
leaked out into the world if it really
was a scroll that duplicated him and it
was a scroll who did it likely the
scroll incapacitated James Rhodes so he
would see it in his fault and he would
see it as this is is a mess that I have
to clean up that's your character
motivation right there again this is
just kind of spitballing more so than
anything else but it is a cool idea to
consider but that leads us into the
question of again why would the Scrolls
turn against humanity because everything
we've seen since the introduction of
Captain Marvel and all the little
tidbits and even with the work on the
peak right that giant orbital space
station that literally orbits Earth that
we saw Nick Fury on at the end of
Spider-Man no way home pretty sure it
was Spider-Man no way home the Scrolls
were working with Humanity so why would
they suddenly turn against them okay so
here's what I think is going on let's
talk about the original secret Invasion
event and Marvel Comics and let's talk
about how that event transpired in the
first place so when it came to the comic
book story there were three major
players that led to the start of secret
Invasion the first one were the
Illuminati the second was Emperor dorak
VII and the third was Princess varenki
now what had happened over the course of
Marvel Comics is you had a conflict
called the cruise scroll War which is
exactly what it sounds like the Korean
the scroll who have been Waging War
against each other for millions of years
the war almost LED led to the
destruction of Earth and that's what led
to the formation of the Illuminati in
Marvel Comics one of the first things
the Illuminati did and in fact the first
thing they did is they traveled to the
home world of the Scrolls and they
basically said do not bring your
conflicts to our doorstep anymore some
of the most powerful beings in the
universe exists on Earth which is an
absolutely correct statement and that if
you do that we will annihilate your
entire Homeworld the Scrolls were not
impressed and they were not concerned
they took out the Illuminati literally
knocked them out they experimented on
their genetics and then re-released them
out there with no knowledge of what had
happened now fast forward to the arrival
of Princess Frankie princess varanki was
a woman who is part of a religious sect
she basically believed that the end was
nigh and that there were these
prophecies that were foretelling the
destruction of the scroll Homeworld
which was previously scrollless but at
this point is terrax IV she told this to
Emperor dorak VII Emperor dorak did not
want to believe it he did not believe
that any of this stuff was true he
didn't want to see his Empire destroyed
but it was also because he was corrupt
and so impressed says for ranky said
like there are prophecies that a world
eater is coming along with a wave you
need to listen to this prepare our
people we have to leave our Homeworld
that ultimately she was exiled to a
desert world now all these prophecies
came true then what Marvel had was a
story called Annihilation where
basically a guy from another reality
named annihilus ended up invading the
main Marvel Universe and tried to
destroy everybody but his forces were
referred to as the annihilation wave
hence the first part of that prophecy
the second thing that happened is that
the world eater was Galactus who showed
up to their Homeworld and consumed it
and basically everybody died the reason
why is because in the aftermath of the
annihilation event what forces the
Scrolls did have had almost been
completely and totally annihilated by
the annihilation waves they were
literally running on what was basically
a skeleton crew as far as their military
might went and even then they never
would have had the ability to take out
Galactus so basically Emperor dorak and
all those guys were destroyed but in the
aftermath of the fact that the
prophecies were true this led to the
Scrolls turning to religion and Princess
varanki they brought her out of Exile
and Princess varenki took over the
scroll Empire and then LED them into the
secret Invasion event in saying that the
prophecies have foretold that in the
destruction of our own world we will
have a new home and that home will be
called Earth and that's why they decided
to take over now do I believe that there
is some kind of crazy event coming in
the secret Invasion TV show that's going
to feature Galactus or the annihilation
wave no but what I do know is that in
times of desperation people believe what
they want to believe and what I imagine
has probably been transpiring here if
only under the current when it came to
the scroll race is that in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the scroll Homeworld
was not destroyed by Galactus it was
destroyed by the cree and what that did
is it left their people scattered and
leaderless they literally just kind of
took over just traveled all over the
place hence the reason why they were
just appearing as human beings on Earth
because Earth was basically a refuge
Planet what you could be potentially
looking at here is that secret invasion
is the end result of a scroll religious
Civil War that on one side you have
Scrolls who follow this religious
ideology handed down to them by
whoever's probably leading the secret
Invasion and in saying like Earth is our
rightful place a manifest destiny kind
of thing on the other side you have
Scrolls who are like that's ridiculous
that people on Earth are our friends and
those are the good guys those are the
ones that are working with Humanity
against the evil Scrolls and that in
turn it's going to lead to that event
ending however it is that it ends up
ending I don't really know here but of
course this takes us back to the
statement that we made at the beginning
of the video which is how can this lead
into a rise of the Thunderbolt so check
this out it's one of the coolest things
so during the secret Invasion storyline
basically Norman Osborne it was really
Deadpool who pulled it off but Norman
Osborne ended up intercepting
information that led to the defeat of
the Scrolls and the secret Invasion
event the reason why this matters is
that in the aftermath of secret Invasion
Iron Man Who had been director of Shield
basically the governments were just like
how could you have possibly missed this
right you are a ridiculous mostly inept
leader so they ended up kicking him out
as director of Shield Norman Osborne
ended up taking over as the new director
of Shield then he immediately disbanded
it and then created what was called
Hammer this basically led to all the
superheroes turning against Norman
Osborne Going Underground and then
basically all the villains replacing the
superheroes so like John Walker becoming
U.S agent potentially becoming Captain
America that kind of a thing and so you
could easily see that instead of us
having Norman Osborne in the MCU we have
Contessa we have Julia Louise Dreyfus
that however it is of the secret
Invasion event ends because Nick Fury
has been underground for so long and I
imagine by most people out there is
believed to be dead that she intercepts
information that makes it look like the
Thunderbolts saved the day and that
positions the Thunderbolts as the
world's Heroes the new quote-unquote
Avengers team grants her a whole new
level of power and a whole new level of
access and then she just starts
positioning the Thunderbolts to become
the ones that are just sort of leading
the superhero show it sounds exactly
like something Contessa would do and
that sets the stage for the Thunderbolts
film it gives us the entire basis for
why that movie exists in the first place
and so that takes us into answering the
question why there's so much comedy in
phase four and just how dark things are
going to get right we know with phase
four with like a She-Hulk and all that
kind of stuff there's all kinds of just
Rip Roar and good fun the Thor movies
have been comedic there hasn't been a
whole lot of seriousness there which I'm
not overly against I think they're doing
that because things are going to be
really really really bad here because we
know the mobile Cinematic Universe this
is technically the Multiverse Saga
that's basically what the movies are
focusing on or really the space fairy
movies more so than anything else for
the earth side of things I think they're
going to initiate dark rain now dark
rain was basically the name of the
entire publishing initiative that Marvel
Comics had when Norman Osborne was the
one running the show it was a very dark
time for superheroes in general and
Norman Osborne did all kinds of crazy
stuff like he literally attacked Asgard
Loki died like the century Robert
Reynolds if you don't know who he is
it's not a very big huge deal he went
crazy and basically almost unleashed the
void there are all kinds of crazy things
that happened right but it was a very
very dark time in Marvel Comics from a
publishing side we already know that
like the whole events of Kane the
Conqueror the Multiverse Saga Avengers
King Dynasty Avengers Secret Wars those
are probably going to be some very very
dark stories and I imagine by the time
we get to the end of it you guys who are
complaining about how happy things are
you're gonna be kind of glad those
moments were there in the first place
things I think are gonna get really
really Bleak but I think on Earth it's
going to be much the same way the
Contessa and the Thunderbolts are going
to usher in dark rain they're going to
usher in an era where people are
basically going to be faced with a
monkey's paw right be careful what you
wish for you just might get it that
might be exactly what's going on here
when it comes to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the Thunderbolts have never
really been a team of good guys they've
never really been like another version
of The Avengers and the first story arc
of the Thunderbolts was actually the the
idea of Baron Zemo positioning them as
what were basically Earth's heroes in
the aftermath of like the Avengers dying
when in reality they just wanted conquer
the world that looks exactly like what
they're going to be doing with the
Thunderbolts film it's literally going
to be Contessa's bid for world
domination by making the Thunderbolts
look like good guys because they save
the world from the secret Invasion so
again let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section right I
mean you think this is going to be one
of those one of those TV shows where
it's literally going to be splintering
out and setting the stage for the for
the reason behind why a bunch of other
Marvel projects exists or do you think
it's going to be just kind of a one-off
story that's going to be like the
eternals film and it just may never be
referenced by anybody again except for
like the She-Hulk TV show maybe kind of
whatever is like a little blip on a page
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later peace